hello everyone and welcome back to the
vhs.com online nations cup
with another game uh between linear
dominguez and eleven arnon not another
game between them it's the first game
between the two of them
we're showing uh but uh it is another
game from the nation's cup and another
one
by lebanese we haven't seen his games
for quite quite some time
uh so it's really interesting really an
exciting opening
featuring a line i haven't seen before
uh and it's not a new line but it's only
been used once and uh
it's obviously obviously been perfected
since the last time it was used so i'm
sure you're going to enjoy it
let's check it out dominguez with the
white pieces opens with
e4 we have e5 uh we have knight to f3
and knight to f6
11 goes for the petrov defense uh and
the immediate of course knight captures
on e5 we have d6 pushing back the knight
knight f3 and now
knight captures on e4 so the classical
variation of the petrol we have d4
and d5 now we have bishop to d3 and
bishop to d6
going for the marshall variation of the
petrov and
dominguez castles we have castles by 11
and c4 now so all very standard stuff we
have c6
and the queen the seat you're putting
more pressure on the knight here and now
instead of
trying to defend the knight uh you just
uh allow white to capture it since uh
you you kind of want uh
a white to give up the bishop there and
the light for a bishop is is very strong
uh and the main move here is knight to
a6 you go knight a6 you threaten knight
b4 to go after the queen and bishop and
after white prevents that then you
later shift the knight maybe to c7 to e6
and so on
but here 11 goes for h6 it's a much
much rarer move still not a new one uh
but okay
uh we have rooked e1 not going for the
capture right away you could capture it
and then after let's say queen capture
surround goes here
queen d3 and bishop g4 black will be
very happy with the extra development
for the for the price of one pawn and
still having the bishop pair
so instead rook to e1 and now putting
more pressure on the e4 knight and
now bishop to e6 putting pressure on the
c4 pawn
uh here we have a train captures
captures and only now
bishop captures an e4 so grabbing the
pawn but giving up the bishop pair we
have d
captures and queen captures followed by
bishop to d5
now seemingly giving up a bishop of
course white can never capture it
because of
captures with check and you lose the
queen so dominguez goes to g4 with the
queen
and now uh it's very interesting black
has a very strong bishop pair you just
sacrificed a pawn it seems like you want
to keep on developing but here queen d7
eleven just offers up
a queen trade being down a pawn which is
what makes this game very
very interesting so we have queen
captures knight captures
uh and now uh sorry knight captures on
d7
uh the interface is not agreeing with me
uh and here uh 11's next move is bishop
captures an f3 so he's down upon and
he's now
going to give up his bishop pair to
create uh four pawn islands uh
uh in white's camp uh and if you try to
try to do something like 95 to to not
allow bishop captures here
then uh we get something like captures
captures rook fe-8 as the rook is
undefended and after bishop to f4
adding another defender here let's say
bishop c5 knight c3 goes after the
bishop bishop here and rook 81. so this
is
one way for white to continue the game
however uh
dominguez decides that it's not
necessary to prevent this he instead
goes knight to c3
he allows this doubling of pawns uh in
exchange for black giving up the bishop
pair
so we have bishop captures on f3g
captures
and this position has been reached
before even though it's already moved 17
but it's been played this year in the
ira float open
uh between nodder abdul satorov and the
raunak
sadvani where white was able to win that
game
after going uh rook after d8 but here we
have bishop to b4 and it's a new move
uh from levan so it is already as of
move 17
that we have a completely new game so
okay we have bishop to d2
dominguez continues developing and now
rook f2d8
and now the point is that uh white is
still up upon black no longer has the
bishop pair however black has two pawn
islands and the white has
four pawn islands which uh the two rooks
eleven has
uh will use the to try and gobble up
those pawns and create threats against
them so the rooks will now try to double
up on the default go after this pawn
uh and so on so it is very interesting
how uh how eleven employs a such tactic
uh with knight to e4 now trading of the
bishops as well we have bishop
characters knight captures and now
knight to f6
uh with knight to b3 defending the d4
pawn and now
b6 uh taking away the d squares from the
white knight
with rook 8 to c1 and now knight to d5
we have a3 taking away the b4 square
from the knight but the knight wants to
come to f4
uh because the white white has no e pawn
or g
pawn to kick it away so the f4 square is
seems like a perfect outpost for the
knight
so rook the d6 preparing to double up on
the d file going after the
the d4 pawn and rook to e4 now already
adding a defender also taking away the
f4 square from black's knight we have
rook
8 to d8 and the now king to f1 starting
to improve the position of the king with
a5 by 11 expanding on the queen side and
now a4 not allowing a further expansion
on the queen side
so g5 by 11 and now rook to c4 adding
yet
another defender to the to the d4 pawn
and now now the knight can move and also
this rook can move
so king g7 11 starts improving the
position of the king and now rook back
to e1
we have king to g6 and now knight to d2
for the moment
leaving the d4 pawn on defender but as
long as this knight is here
uh it's not a problem so 11 goes for
knight to b4 now that you've played a4
uh the b4 square is available to the
knight and the pawn is once again under
attack so knight b3 defending it and
now knight the d3 attacking the pawn and
the the rook on e1 so rookie two
defending everything and now
only now knights to f4 uh and now the
knight comes to f4 with tempo so you
again have to move the rook
and now rook to f6 now 11 will shift his
attention to the
ah to the f3 pawn and f2 pawn as the
pawns are doubled here
so knight back to d2 uh adding a
defender to the f3 pawn
and now knight to d3 now attacking the
rook ended the b2 pawn
so uh you have to play rook to b1 which
dominguez does
and now rook to f4 now adding another
attacker to the d4 pawn problem is
you've now left your
b6 pawn undefended so dominguez
immediately goes after it rook c6
check king g7 and now rook captures on
b6 but now 11 is also free to gobble up
some of the pawn so rook d captures on
d4
putting pressure now on the a4 pawn as
well so b3 defending it and
now comes a a move that obviously
11 played going into all of this
knight captures on f2 and it makes sense
you open up a discovery here which means
you've just grabbed back the pawn
so if you go after this then just
captures here and after the king moves
somewhere let's say here you just grab
this pawn as well and now
uh this pawn will fall uh otherwise
you're not gonna be able to push
anything on on the queen side
and with the three connected passports
on the king side black
black will be winning this position so
instead king the e2 was played by
dominguez and
now rook to h4 just going after that h2
pawn
uh we have knight to f1 defending and
now knight the d3
uh just uh uh improving the position of
the knight
uh we have rook to b5 now putting
pressure on the a5 pawn and now
knight to f4 with check pushing the king
back king f2 and then now comes
rook to d3 here 11 is planning rook c3
to c2
which will put a lot of pressure on the
white king so here
uh here you should go real captures on
a5 it seems uh
seems like a bold move but you should do
it and after rook c3 then you go b4
you start pushing the pawns and black
will have to
go after the pawn you will not be able
to start attacking the white king with
some like knight d3 checking g1 and
captures here
but this will also give you time to
start pushing your a pawn so this is
definitely
the way to go for white however
dominguez played rook to e5 instead
which really took me some time to to
figure out what he was trying to do
maybe maybe go after rook to e3 to try
and trade off the rooks
the problem is after 11's rook the c3 he
only then
captured an a5 so basically he wasted a
move with rook to e5 and only then
capturing here
so rook to h3 and now comes rook to b5
uh preparing of course to push the a
pawn and now
rook captures on f3 grabbing the pawn
with check so rook h captures an f3
uh sorry about that just give me a
second
[Music]
sorry about that it was it was the
mailman uh so
rook h captures on f3 with check uh and
now king the g1 so already uh dominguez
king is uh
not not feeling all all that great with
with the two rooks and knight in front
of it
uh we have rook to c2 now by 11 uh
preparing to put the other rook to f2
and put a lot of pressure here
and now rook to b6 uh probably
preventing the king from
from going into into the game but levin
needs no king he goes for rook f2f2
now uh there are definitely some some
threats here
uh and dominguez starts pushing his pawn
as there there is not much you can do
here so 11 played
rook to g2 check king h1 and okay
luckily the h2 pawn is protected
but feel free to pause the video here
and finish this game with
the absolute best move for for black
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting the uh
unstoppable mating four
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's knight to h3
and now there is no defense against rook
to g1 mate
uh and uh well if you wanna move the
knight so that
the rook guards the g1 square it doesn't
really help you since if you move the
knight
then this is made uh as the knight
covers the g1 square
so you haven't really accomplished much
uh and yeah again i
i have to mention this i say a mate in
four because
uh with best the defense is mating for
but otherwise in reality it's actually
just a game over
after knight to h3 because here it's
made him for because white can play
silly moves and that's why
yeah it's uh you're supposed to say it's
it's a mate and four
when in fact it's really just game over
uh but yeah now i just wanted to mention
that as well and here are the standings
after four rounds
uh so here is uh round three there you
have it uh usa against rest of the world
one uh all the games on board on first
three boards were drawn
and the decisive game was irina crush
versus dinara
sadwaka with irina crush winning
and usa winning the match against rest
of the world then we have india and
europe europe one
uh two and a half to one and a half uh
with the winner being 11 versus vidit
we've seen that game already uh and uh
china versus russia we have a we have a
time uh dingler and defeated yaniponishi
and vladislavartme have defeated
with all the other games wrong and this
uh are the
pairings from round four uh russia
defeated rest of the world ian nipon she
defeated timur
rajab and sergey karakin defeated jorge
cory
then europe defeated usa with three to
one uh
11 again it's the game we've just seen
defeated
linear dominguez uh and uh nana zagnitsa
defeated anna zatonski
and we have china and india china
defeated india with
van gaal defeating vedic gujarati who
loses his
third game in a row uh so tough break
for vidit and tough break for india
as in the final standings this is what
it means china is leading
the uh fide uh combinations cup with
seven points followed by usa and europe
with five
russia with four rest of the world two
and india with one point so far
so we'll see what happens and who will
reach the super final
so yeah that's uh the game i do hope you
enjoyed it i would like to thank
benjamin robertson darcy howe uh roger
alexanderson elita tan and
jean-francois bond for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the offi
nations cup and
whatever else i manage the time for uh
and also sorry about sending you the
invitation to the tournament i really
thought it was friday and it's
only thursday so we're gonna do the
tournament tomorrow
uh so thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day